a city is like a brain it develops from
a small Center and slowly grows and
changes leaving many old parts still
functioning
New York can't afford to suspend its
water supply or its transportation
system while they're being replaced by
something more efficient changes have to
happen piecemeal and that's how it is
for the brain there is no way for
evolution to rip out the ancient
interior of the brain because of its
imperfections and replace it with
something of more modern manufacture the
brain and the city both must function
continuously during the renovation
that's why our limbic system is
surrounded by the cerebral cortex the
old part is in charge of too many vital
mechanisms for it to be replaced
altogether so it's sometimes
counterproductive but that's a necessary
consequence of evolution the city is a
gift of the cerebral cortex but the
brains language is not encoded in the
DNA of genes because the vocabulary of
life is too small our brains need a
language with 10,000 times as many words
the information content of the human
brain expressed in bits is probably
comparable to the total number of
connections among the neurons about a
thousand trillion bits
if all the contents of your brain would
transcribe into written language it
would amount to vastly more books that
are contained in the largest libraries
on earth the equivalent of more than
four billion books are inside your head
the brain is a very big place in a very
small space
[Music]
it's written in those neurons pioneered
by the undersea microbial mats these are
tiny electrochemical switching elements
typically a few hundredths of a
millimeter across each of us has 86
billion neurons comparable to the number
of stars in the Milky Way galaxy the
neurons and their parts axons and
dendrites synapses and the cell bodies
themselves make up a network in the
brain many neurons have thousands of
connections with their neighbors
dendrites those pathways sent out by
neurons to connect with other neurons
extend these nerve cells to synapses
until they create a full-blown network
of consciousness
[Music]
[Music]
the neuro chemistry of the brain is
astonishingly busy the circuitry of a
machine more wonderful than any devised
by humans your brain functions are due
to those hundred trillion neural
connections that make you you your
deepest feelings of love and awe
those moments when we glimpse the
grandeur of nature and all the elegant
architecture of consciousness are made
possible by those connections this is
the essence of emergence tiny units of
matter operating collectively to become
something much more than themselves to
enable the cosmos to know itself but
there's a vision of emergence that takes
it even higher can we know the universe
and will it ever come to know us
[Music]